[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم تكن زياره
الرئيس الامريكي بايدن الى كييف بمناسبه
مرور عام على الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
ايثانا بالتصعيد الم تدخل الحرب عامها
الثاني بينما يزداد الوضع سوءا الا يبدو
الوضع صعبا امام الجيش الروسي لكن في
المقابل الا يبدو الغرب مستعدا لفتح باب
الحوار مع روسيا لوقف الحرب الم يتلقف
الجميع المقترحات الصينيه الاخيره الا
يبدو بوتين مصمما على الاستمرار في الحرب
حتى يحقق كامله اهدافه اسئله اطرحها هنا
في الاستوديو على السيناتور الدكتور زياد
سبسبي نائب رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
الاسبق في مجلس الشيوخ الروسي وعبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من برلين على جيال عمر
عضو البرلمان الالماني
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس لو بدات
معك جيان عمر من المانيا عام على التدخل
او الحرب في اوكرانيا ماذا بعد
تحياتي يا دكتور فيصل لك ولضيفك الكريم
ولمشاهديك الكرام في الحقيقه عام على
الدمار في اوكرانيا عام على المجازر
والجرائم التي يرتكبها الجيش الروسي
باوامر من بوتين في اوكرانيا عام على
الماسي التي سببها بوتين للشعب الاوكراني
المسالم بدون اي مبرر هذا الغزو الروسي
الذي بدا قبل عام من الان لم يكن له اي
مبرر لا عسكريا ولا
جيوسياسيين حيث ان اوكرانيا لم تعتدي على
الاراضي الروسيه ولم يكن هناك اي استفزاز
من قبل الناتو على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لروسيا لذلك هذا هو
عام على جرائم الحرب التي كان العالم
شاهدا عليها
شاهدنا مجازر حصلت في المدن الاوكرانيه
نشاهد حتى الان تدمير للبنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه حرب على المدنيين بوت ونظامه
اثبتوا بانهم نظام خارق مارق للقوانين
الدوليه هو يحاول زعزعه الامن الدولي
يحاول زعزعه الامن في اوروبا بعد الحربين
العالميتين الاولى والثانيه استطاعت
اوروبا ان تضع قوانين
ومعايير لحقوق الانسان والاحترام الدول
للسيادات الدول الاخرى والجيرانهم وحدودهم
وبوتين اخترق كل هذه
الحواجز وتجاوز الخطوط الحمراء ايضا في
الرابع والعشرين من شهر فبراير العام
الماضي ولذلك هذه الحرب هي وثيقه سوف تدخل
التاريخ حول الجرائم الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وسوف تبقى وصمه عار على جبين القياده
الروسيه وايضا كل المشاركين في هذه الحرب
على اوكرانيا وفي المقابل ايضا اؤكد لكم
هنا من برلين بان الموقف الغربي واضح ولم
يتغير ولم يتزحزح على العكس تماما هنا في
الطريق الى الاستوديو التقطت لكم هذه
الصوره هذه الصوره توضح دبابه روسيه تم
تدميرها في اوكرانيا والان تم وضعها امام
السفاره الروسيه في برلين وهؤلاء هم
المتظاهرون الالمان والاوكرانيون يضعون
هذه الدبابه التي تم تدميرها في اوكرانيا
على يد الجيش الاوكراني لكي تكون شاهدا
على الفشل الروسي حتى اليوم في اوكرانيا
ايضا في المقابل كانت هناك كان هناك مئات
الالاف من الشعوب الاوروبيه هذه مظاهره
برلين مئات الالاف تضامنوا مع اوكرانيا
واكدوا على ان الدعم الاوروبي لاوكرانيا
مستمر لان الشعب الاوكراني يدافع اليوم عن
القيم الاوروبيه يدافع عن حقوق الانسان
يدافع عن الديمقراطيته وحريته لذلك الدعم
الغربي سوف يبقى مستمرا لهذا الشعب الذي
اظهر بطوله ليس لها مثيل وفي المقابل
الجيش الروسي يتقهقر حتى اليوم ولم يحقق
ولو 1% من الاهداف التي زعم بانه يحارب
اوكرانيا لاجلها دكتور زياد
ايضا مساء الخير دكتور ولضيفك الكريم
والساده المشاهدين طبعا نحن في حوارنا حول
هذا الموضوع يجب ان نتكلم
بالواقع كيف ومتى ولماذا ونبتعد قليلا عن
العواطف والمشاعر الانسانيه التي يجب ان
تكون متواجده عند كل انسان
نبدا بالموضوع الشعب الاوكراني البو سالم
نحن لا نتكلم عن الشعب الاوكراني ابدا
وروسيا تعتبر الشعب الاوكراني شعب شقيق
وكما تعلمون بان اوكرانيا وبلغاريا وروسيا
من الشعوب الثلاثيه وفي نهايه الامر يبقى
يبقون شعبا واحدا ولكن عندما ولكن اذا
عدنا الى الوراء الى عام 2014 عندما حصلت
ما يسمى بين قوسين ثوره ميدان اوروبا في
كيف وجدنا بان السفاره الامريكيه
والمستشارين الامريكيون كانوا في ارض
الساحه وكان حتى احداهن من كبار
الدبلوماسيات الامريكيات توزع قطع الحلوى
والمعجنات على
المشاغبين وليس على الثوار لو ان روسيا لو
ان لروسيا نوايا عدوانيه تجاه اوكرانيا
كدوله لكانت امدت الرئيس المخلوع او الذي
هرب في عام 2014 الى روسيا لدمعه لدعمته
بالقوى العسكريه وكان لديه ايضا قوه كبيره
من اجهزه الامن وزاره الداخليه والاجهزه
الامنيه الاوكرانيه ولكن روسيا رات بانه
من الواجب ان يكون لدى الشعب الاوكراني
كشعب ولكن يجب ان يكون لدى الغرب عندما
اتكلم عن الغرب انا اعدي اعني بالذات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان نحن في
روسيا لا نعترف بان هنالك يوجد اوروبا
مستقله بقراراتها السياسيه او الاقتصاديه
او حتى الاخلاقيه
زعزعه الامن الدولي من الذي كان يزعزع
الامن الدولي كان على مستوى العالم او على
المستوى الاقليمي في اخر ثلاثين عاما من
الذي هرب من افغانستان في اغسطس عام 2021
وترك حلفائه من الافغان ومن غيرهم مما
وثقوا وامنوا واخلصوا للمجتمع الغربي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في قضيه
تحرير افغانستان خرجوا خروج مذل وهزيل
موضوع الدبابه الان طبعا هذا الامر كان
موجودا ولكن لم يضيف الاخ جان بانه بعد
ساعات توالت حشود كبيره من الالمان وخاصه
ممن كانوا يعيشون في المانيا الديمقراطيه
التي اصبحت بعد ذلك جزء من المانيا وتوحدت
مع المانيا الغربيه
حمل الورود بمئات الورود وايضا هذا الامر
كان موجود في الصحافه الاوروبيه وغيرها
لذلك التكلم اليوم الحديث عن ان هنالك
تماسكا
شعبيا داخل حلف الناتو او داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا الامر على الارض لا يمكن ان
يثبته احد هنالك اختلاف كبير في دول
الناتو هنالك حتى في موضوع
العقوبات الاقتصاديه على روسيا حتى
المانيا اليوم يجب ان يعلم وهو عضو في
البرلمان
الالماني بان المانيا الى هذا اليوم
تستورد الغاز الروسي وتستورد النفط الروسي
وحتى الفحم الحجري التي تبتعد عنه الدول
الاوروبيه المتقدمه وعلى راسها البانيا في
هذا العام اخذت 29% من احتياجاتها من
الفحم الحجري من روسيه من روسيا الرقم
يمكن ان اسميه هو 13 مليون طن من الفحم
وهذه ارقام كبيره لدوله لدوله المانيا
وجدنا بان هنغاريا وهي عضو في الناتو لها
موقف مختلف صربي لها موقف مختلف ايطاليا
لها تحفظات كبيره عن العقوبات التي تفرضها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم الفائز
نعم اليوم الفائز الوحيد هو فقط الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تصور الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تبعد اكثر من عشره الاف
كيلو متر عن اوروبا تتحدث عن الامن القومي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبما يثير من
الضحك ايضا ازاله تذكرون المحادثات ما بين
طالبان وامريكا في قطر كان هنالك بند
رئيسي ان تتعهد طالبه في المستقبل ان لا
تكون داغستان منطلقا لعمليات ارهابيه او
لاي عمليات يمكن ان تؤثر على الامن
الامريكي
كيف يمكن ان يؤثر هذا العمل بعد عشره الاف
كيلو مترات نحن اليوم نعتبر بان الدول
الغربيه اصبحت رهينه بشكل مباشر وبكل معنى
الكلمه لدى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عندما ارادت النرويج والدنمارك
النظر في تخفيف اسعار الطاقه المورده الى
اوروبا وخاصه الى المانيا وفرنسا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اعترضت على هذا الامر
وقالت نحن في مجتمع حر راس مالي للمنتج
والمستهلك حق الاتفاق حول موضوع الاسعار
واليوم اخجان اود
يعني اعطيه ليس نصيحه ولكن اعطيه فكره
رئيسيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اليوم
تعمل على تفريغ اوروبا على تفريغ المانيا
اقتصاديا سياسي اقتصاديا كيف خروج المعامل
الكبيره التي اليوم تعمل على في المانيا
الغربيه في المانيا سوف يخرجون على سبيل
المثال في مدينه فولسبور كما نعلم في
ساكسونيا السفلى هاي مدينه سكانها من 125
الف مواطن نسمه منهم 55 الف عامل يعملون
في هذا المعمل شركه
الشركه فولكس فاكن قررت الذهاب الى اين
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لماذا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقدم اعفاءات
ضريبيه
السعر منافس سعر الطاقه ان كان من الغاز
والنفط وكل مستلزمات المواد الاوليه هي
موجوده في امريكا واسعارها اقل بكثير مما
هي الان في المانيا والمستثمر كما نعلم
بانه جبان دائما يبحث عن مكان امن من
مصلحه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تجعل
من المنطقه الاوروبيه او بنقول من قاره
اوروبا القديمه والجديده بما فيها الدول
الاوروبيه الشرقيه التي كانت في حلف وارسو
ان تعيشهم في جو من الرعب والخوف وعدم
الامان والان اخترعوا البعبع الروسي الذي
يريد ان يحتل بولونيا والمانيا وفرنسا
وانجلترا وكل هذه الامور روسيا لا تريد
احت لال اي دوله روسيا تريد ان تحافظ على
حدودها
الجغرافيه ومصالحها الجويه السياسيه
بالاعتماد على نفسها
ملاحظه اخيره قبل العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا رسميا تقدمت روسيا بطلب الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتوقيع
اتفاقيه اهم شيء هو ان تكون اوكرانيا
خاليه من السلاح ان تتعهد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان لا تضم اوكرانيا الى
حلف الناتو وان يكون الامن كامل لا يمكن
ان يكون الامن مجزا بحيث تكون المال
الغربي او اوروبا ولا المتحده الامريكيه
في مكان امن وفي حاله امنه ولكن على حساب
نقص الامن باتجاه روسيا الاتحاديه جيهان
عمر كيف ترد
يا دكتور زياد انت عم تقول روسيا ليست هنا
في اوكرانيا لاحتلالها ماذا يفعل الجيش
الروسي اذا في اوكرانيا ماذا كانت تفعل
الدبابات الروسيه في كيف وحاولت محاصرتكيف
ماذا تفعل روسيا من مجازر في اوكرانيا هذه
مجزره بوتشا حيث تم اعدام المدنيين فيها
وهذه الصور التي وصلت الى جميع انحاء
العالم وجميع الصحفيين العالم كانوا
موجودين هناك انظر الى حجم الدمار الروسي
الذي سببته اله الحرب العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ماذا يفعل هذا الجيش هل يوزع
الورود على الاوكرانيين ام يقوم بتدمير
البنيه التحتيه هذا الجيش الروسي ما خلفه
في المدن الاوكرانيه هل يقوم بتوزيع
الورود هناك يعني انا لا افهم هذا المنطق
حقيقه منطق انكار الحقيقه بهذا الشكل لا
استطيع ان اتفهمها بالمطلق يعني انت دخلت
في سرديتك الى الماضي والى الاتحاد
السوفيتي وبان الشعوب اخويه هل تعلم بان
بوتين نعم هناك اخوه بين الشعب الاوكراني
والشعب الروسي والشعوب اسلاميه بشكل عام
ولكن بوتين دمر هذه الروابط بين هذه
الشعوب اليوم كانت هناك
كان هناك تصريح
لعمده احد المدن الاوكرانيه حيث قالت في
بان بوتين وروسيا تستطيعان ان يسيطروا على
اوكرانيا في حاله وحيده فقط اذا قاموا
باباده الشعب الاوكراني بشكل كامل لن نقوم
بالركوع لروسيا ولن نقبل في اي يوم من
الايام ان ننضم الى روسيا هذه هي كلمات
الاوكرانيين انفسهم هل رايتم الاراده التي
يظهرها الجيش الاوكراني والشعب الاوكراني
في هذه الحرب حتى هناك بعض الزعماء
الاوروبيين لم يكنوا يتوقع ان يكون هناك
هذا الحجم الضخم من المقاومه من قبل
الاوكران امام جيش الروسي لان الجميع كان
يعتقد بان وبوتين على وجه الخصوص كان
يعتقد بان الدخول الى اوكرانيا هي نزهه
عده اسابيع في اسوء الاحوال اشهر وسوف
يسيطرون على كامل اوكرانيا انت في بدايه
حديثك تكلمت عن نقطه حقيقه تكشف النوايا
الروسيه في اوكرانيا نعم بالفعل الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا لم تبدا في العام
الماضي وانما بدات في العام 2014 حينما
اراد الشعب الاوكراني الانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه حينما خرج الشعب الاوكراني
الى الشوارع واسقطوا النظام يانوكوفيتش
الذي كان مرتبطا وممولا من قبل الكريم
حينها قامت روسيا باقتطاع جزء من اوكرانيا
وضمها الى روسيا وهي جزيره القرن وقامت
روسيا بزرع ميليشيات انفصاليه اجراميه
تمارس القتل في دونيتسكو لوهانكس في شرق
اوكرانيا نعم روسيا لا تخشى من الناتو
وروسيا لا تخشى من
الشعب الاوكراني ولكن روسيا تخشى من
الديمقراطيات على حدودها لانها لا تريد
رياح الديمقراطيه والحريه ان تهب الى
شعبها لذلك قاموا بمحاصره اوكرانيا
وباضعاف اوكرانيا ومحاوله زعزعتها ولكن كل
هذه المحاولات فشلت انت تتحدث عن الماضي
اتمنى ان يا دكتور فيصل ومن ضيفك ايضا ان
يكون التركيز على الحاضر على الان الخسائر
الروسيه في اوكرانيا على وجه على على على
صعيد
المثال على سبيل المثال وليس الحصر اكثر
من 140 قتيل روسي حاليا في اوكرانيا اكثر
من 3900 دبابه اكثر من 6500 مدرعه عسكريه
اكثر من 286 طائره هليكوبتر اكثر من 236
نظام دفاع جوي اكثر من 18 سفينه عسكريه من
بينها سفينه بوسليفكا التي كانت تعتبر
السفينه الرئيسيه في الاسطوره الروسي في
البحر الاسود اكثر من 298 طائره من مختلف
الانواع واكثر من 2000 طائره درون بدون
طيار يعني هل اعد ام اكتفي بهذا القدر
الخسائر الروسيه في اوكرانيا فادحه لان
الجيش
الروسي كان يتوقع بان الدخول الى اوكرانيا
واحتلالها هي مساله اسابيع الجيش
الاوكراني جيش ضعيف ولن يستطيع المقام
ولكن ما اظهره الشعب الاوكراني والجيش
الاوكراني والقياده الاوكرانيه فاجا الروس
وفاجا العالم وحتى بعض القاده الاوروبيين
وايضا النقطه الاخرى ان هذا هذا الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا
رص الصفوف الاوروبيه هناك اليوم وحده على
جميع الاصعده في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والمعسكر الغربي بضروره مواجهه روسيا في
اوكرانيا لانه اذا تم الغض النظر عن
الدخول الروسي الى اوكرانيا فسوف يكون
الدور بعدها على مولدافيا وعلى جورجيا
وعلى دول البلطيق وغيرها لذلك هناك وحده
في القرار الاوروبي فيما يتعلق بضروره وضع
حد لروسيا لانها تجاوزت الخطوط الحمراء في
الرابع والعشرين من شهر الثاني استعامل
الماضي لذلك ابشرك من هذا المنبر ايضا
واتمنى ان توصل هذه هذا الى القياده
الروسيه بان الموقف الاوروبي وانا قلتها
دكتور فيصل كنت في برنامجك قبل انطلاق
الحرب باسبوع وانت تتذكر قلتها بانه اذا
حاولت روسيا الدخول الى اوكرانيا فسيكون
هناك رد على روسيا لم يسبق له مثيل
والحزمه الاخيره الحزمه العاشره من
العقوبات التي فرضها للاتحاد الاوروبي على
على روسيا لم يسبق لها مثيل هي حزمه تشمل
حتى القطاعات المدنيه الروسيه لذلك يجب ان
نتوقف عن بيع الاوهام انتم تبيعون الاوهام
للجيش للشعب الروسي بان المعركه هي في
اتجاه النصر ولكن الخسائر التي قمت بتعداد
جزء منها في اوكرانيا هي خسائر فادحه
لروسيا اتمنى ان تتكلم عن هذه الخسائر عن
خسائر الاقتصاد الروسي اتمنى عدم ذكر
الحقائق التي ليس لها اساس من الصحه انت
تقول بان المانيا لا تزال تستورد الغاز
والنفط الروسي هذا غير صحيح المانيا تحررت
من الغاز الروسي ومن النفط الروسي والان
الاتحاد الاو روبي فرض عقوبات على جميع
الدول التي تسيطر على التي تحاول الارتفاع
على العقوبات الاوروبيه والغربيه دكتور
زياد
سابدا من الخسرات الاقتصاديه
طبعا اذا تكلمنا عن الخسائر طبعا نحن
دائما نثمن
ونحرص بان لا يكن هنالك اي خسائر بشريه لا
من الجانب الاوكراني المدني ولا من جانب
الروسي
اظن بان العالم كله شهد افلام الفيديو
ومقاطع الفيديو التي من خلالها كانوا
مقاتلين ازوف
ذوي ذوي الاتجاه الفاشي كانوا يطلقون
الرصاص على اجساد
وارجل على اجسام المواطنين
الجنود الروس هذا امر اكيد موجود بالنسبه
للمقاومه الجيش الاوكراني المقاومه اليوم
تحتصر فقط بالاسلحه التكتيكيه عاليه
التكنولوجيا التي
يوردها الغرب والسيد يعرف بان شلت مسكين
يعني هيك بالعربي والله زعلانه عليه انه
ليس قادرا على اتخاذ قرار بتوريد الدبابات
بشكل سريع في وقتها او الامتناع عن توريد
الدبابات لانه غير صاحب راي على ارض
المعركه اليوم اثبتت جيش الروسي بانه قادر
ليس فقط على الانتصار او تحرير الاراضي
التي تم ضمها الان الى روسيا الاتحاديه
وهي دونباس
ولوغونسون وزابالوجيا
قادرين ليس فقط على حمايتها وانما ببطء
الاستمرار
نسي الاخ جان ان يقول بان خلال اسبوعين
بحر ازوف اصبح بحر الروسيه والى الان بحرا
روسيا وسيبقى بحر الروسيا روسيا لا تريد
ان تحارب لو انها ارادت ان تحارب احدا او
تخاف من الديمقراطيه كما نعلم دول البلطيق
الثلاث كانوا اول جمهوريات اشتراكيه دخلت
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى دخلوا الى مجلس
الناتو لا يوجد هنالك اي عقده من قبل
روسيا او القياده الروسيه بانها تخاف او
تتحسس من وجود دوله ديمقراطيه محاذيه لها
اذا كان الغرب اليوم يفكر او يعتبر
اوكرانيا بانها دوله ديمقراطيه وهو بنفسه
يقول بان اوكرانيا هي من اكثر الدول فسادا
وتخلفا وبان كل المساعدات التي كانت تقدم
بعد 2014 كانت تسرق
ولا نريد الان الدخول بتفاصيل قصه ابن
الرئيس بيدا وموضوعه مع القصب وموضوعه مع
المدعي الاوكراني يعني هذه امور كانت
معروفه بالنسبه للخساره الاقتصاديه كما
اراد في الارقام خلينا اذا نعتمد للارقام
فقط في النصف الاول في النصف الاول من عام
حصل على ارباح
بمقدار اثنين فاصله سته يعني اكثر من
مرتين ونصف من اربع خلال سته اشهر من
العام الاول
للقسم الاول من العام 2022 طيب ماذا اضاعت
امريكا
المانيا المانيا فقط في العام الماضي على
فرق اسعار الغاز هو 100 مليار دولار يعني
هل يظن الشعب الالماني بان المانيا كشعب
وكاققتصاد كبير لا يحتاج الى الصناعات
الثقيله هل هو وافق على هروب الصناعات
الثقيله هل هو موافق على ان يكون تابعه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه علما بان
المانيا هي التي كانت الجهه المحركه
ممكن نقول
المؤثره اللوبي المؤثر في اقناع بيد على
افتتاح الخط السيل الشمالي رقم اثنين الذي
فجرته الولايات الامريكيه طبعا هذا الامر
غير رسميا ولكن كل الشكوك
تتجه نحو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول
الغربيه ومن المضحك ان يقول ممكن حتى يعني
المخابرات الروسيه ممكن كمان ايضا دخلت
الى النرويج والدنمارك واجرت عمليه
استخباراتيه عمليه عسكريه وفجرت هذه
الانابيب طبعا نحن لا نبرر قتل اي شخص
ابدا ولكن يجب ان يعرف العالم بان روسيا
لها الحق الكامل ان تحافظ على مصالحها
وعلى حدودها وعلى مواطنيها مثلها مثل اي
دوله اخرى في الايام الاخيره ارجو ان
الاستاذ جان اذا كان بيعطينا رايك كمان
الغرب يقول يجب علينا ان ننتصر على روسيا
انتصار نصا استراتيجيا ما معنى النصر
الاستراتيجي
عدم تواجد دوله زوال الدوله
النصر العسكري على روسيا النصف العسكري
على روسيا مستحيل وكما قال الرئيس بوتين
عندما نصل الى مرحله ونجد بان روسيا لن
تبقى على خارطه العالم
فسنرتئي بانه هذا الامر ينطبق على الدول
الاخرى ايضا اذا الغرب
اوروبا ليس لها حق ايضا في الوجود هذا قال
السيد بوتين وقال انه هذا ليس تهديد ولكن
لكي تعلموا باننا نحن لن نكون السباقين
ولا في اي هجوم على الاخر اذا اليوم قررت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تقول نحن
مع الحوار بين اوكرانيا وروسيا جاهزه
الكلام لك
يعني بصراحه انا تمنيت ان تكون الحلقه
تتجه نحو التحليل ونحو تناول الحقائق ولكن
الاخ زياد يتكلم عن الاوهام ومرار حاولت
في البدايه ان اعطيه ارقام وادله ولكن هو
يتحرب من الاجابه لا اعلم لماذا لان موقفه
ضعيف وهذا انا بتفهمه كل من يدافع عن هذا
الشيطان الموجود في موسكو واسمه بوتين
موقفه ضعيف على شيء طبيعي ولكن على الاقل
القليل
انت تكلمت كثيرا
ارجو الابتعاد عن الشخصنه اذا برايك من هو
من هو من هو بيت شخص من هو شولت الذي يرسل
الدبابات والقنابل التي
انا لست محامي
المانيا في 2014 هل قرات يا سيد جان بان
سيده مركل عفوا السيده مركز قالت نعم نحن
كنا نوقع على اتفاقيه ولكننا نعلم باننا
لن نقوم بتنفيذها كنا نريد ان نفوز في
الوقت لقد خدعنا روسيا ولقد خضعنا بين
قوسين الانفصاليين لذلك في هذه الفتره
صحيحه يعني من دكتور فيصل في برنامجك
الحديث عن كلامه تصريحات ليس لها اساس من
الصحه والغرب يعبئ اوكرانيا بالاسلحه مثل
المتعاطي للمخدرات الذي كلم هذا الكلام
عيب عيب
نحن الان نعم
نتكلم بلغه الوقائع والارقام وليس التحليل
التحليلات انت قاعد هناك بتحلل تعال زور
انت
ساتكلم باللغه الارقام ولكن انت
وانا اعطيك كلمه بانك لا احد يمس شعره من
راسك وتشاهد بعينك ما يحدث هناك انت اعمتك
الدعايه الغربيه التي في كل مكان
ارجوك ان في هذه المناسبات الغربيه خليني
اكمل انا لم اسمع ان تكون اليوم المتحده
الامريكيه خليني اكمل
العراق ايضا دقيقه تفضل سيد جيش الكلام لك
يا اخي خليني احكي انا لست بحاجه
الغربيه لانني شاهدت ما فعله بوتين وما
فعلته روسيا في سوريا انا سوري الاصل
واعلم حجم الجرائم الروسيه التي ارتكبها
ذات النظام في روسيا شاهدت المجازر التي
ارتكبت في المدن السوريه هي نفسها لهذه
المشاهد تتكرر لو هذه هذا مجمع تجاري في
اوكرانيا تم تدميره وهذا يذكرنا بايضا
بالمدن السوريه بحمص وحما وغيرها التي
دمرها الطيران
بحاجه
مستودع وروسيا
اعلى الغرب
هذا ليس مستودع
تك
سوف تكون مشروعا
صحيحا ومشروعا
وهدفا مشروعا لكل انواع الاسلحه الروسيه
ان كانت من الجو او البحر او من الارض طيب
تفضل يا جيهان
يا اخ زياداتو يا اخي
خليني اتكلم يعني في البرلمان
بان الاسلحه الغربيه لا يا اخي
الاسلحه الغربيه سوف تسمح لاوكرانيا ان
تفوز على على روسيا او تنتصر على روسيا
يعني الواحد يقول لك يكون في عال براسه
بكل وضوح الجواب الجواب بكل وضوح نعم
الجواب بكل وضوح نعم لان الجيش الروسي كان
يعتقد بانه ذاهب الى نزهه الى اوكرانيا
وفشل شاهدنا الدبابات الروسيه تحاصر كيف
لعده اسابيع وتقهقر الجيش الروسي على
اسوار كيف نعم اكثر من عام وعددت لك حجم
الخسائر الروسيه اكثر من 140 الف قتيل
ومرتزق روسي في اوكرانيا نعم الاسلحه
الغربيه
الجيش الروسي يا اخي لا تقاطعني يا اخي
يعني مش
لا لا تناقشني بالارقام لانك لانك لانك
موقفك ضعيف لذلك لن تستطيع المواجهه
بالارقام وانما بالخطابات والشعارات
نعرفها هذه اللغه هذه اللغه التي استخدمها
سابقا ابواق الانظمه العربيه ليست بجديده
علينا حقيقه ولكن انا تحدثت لك بالارقام
والوقائع اين هو الجيش الروسي الان جيش
دوله عظمى تريد مواجهه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه غير قادر على مواجهه دوله عدد
سكانها 40 مليون نسمه جيش الاوكراني كان
غير مجهز بالاسلحه هناك دعوات منذ سنوات
من قبل اوكرانيا للغرب من اجل تسليحها ولم
يقم الغرب بتسليحه وانا كعض برلمان الماني
انتقد دولتي انتقد المانيا انها لم تستمع
الى الاستغاثات الاوكرانيه سابقا اقولها
بالفيلم الان وايضا وزير الاقتصاد ووزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه الذين وهي من حزمه من
حزب الخضر الالماني انتقدوا الحكومات
الالمانيه السابقه لانها لم تقدم الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا قبل الدخول رو الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بهذا الشكل نعم بعد ان
تم تقديم الاسلحه لاوكرانيا الجيش
الاوكراني والشعب الاوكراني يظهر بطوله
ليس لها مثيل وهذا يزعج الكريم ويزعج
قاعده الغرب نسمع التصريحات سخيفه من
شخصيات مثل مديادف الذي يقول علنا على
التلفاز التلفزيون الاوكراني الروسي بانه
سوف يقوم باداده اوكرانيا وباباده الشعب
الاوكراني هذه لغه خطاب المنهزم المنهزم
الذي يقوم بقتل المدنيين اظهرت لك الصور
مجزره بوتشا ومجره ماريوبول وغيرهم من
المجازر التي تم ارتكابها بحق المدنيين
هذا دليل بان هذا الجيش الروسي هو جيش
جبان غير قادر حتى على مواجهه جيش اضعف
منه عسكريا
على الصعيد العسكري ايضا لذلك لا يمكن
الحديث الان عن انتصار روسيا ولا حتى عن
تحقيق جزء من الاهداف طيب الاهداف خلينا
بالمنطق سوف اتي لك اترك الارقام لانك غير
قادر على الرد الارقام ولكن تعال الى
الاهداف التي اعلن عنها بوتين مرارا
وتكرارا بوتين قال بانه يود ان ينهي الحكم
النازي في اوكرانيا اليوم
كان ضيفا على جميع برلمانات العالم تم تم
استقباله في جميع البرلمانات الديمقراطيه
في العالم في حين ان بوتين معزول دوليا
ومنبوس دوليا لا احد يستقبله على الصعيد
العسكري قال فوتين بانه سوف
ينهي اوكرانيا عسكريا ولكن الان حجم
الاسلحه التي دخلت الى اوكرانيا الدبابات
مادر الدفاعيه من المانيا الدبابات
الالمانيه الهجوميه
طائرات بدون الطيار الغربيه الاسلحه
الصواريخ والنظام الباتريوت الامريكي
الموجود في اوكرانيا اليوم الان ونحن
نتحدث في هذه المقابله الاف عناصر الجيش
الاوكراني يتم تدريبهم في بولونيا وفي
المانيا وفي بريطانيا وفي امريكا
مختلف الانواع الاسلحه اليوم الجيش
الاوكراني اقوى بكثير من السابق كانت هناك
الدول محايده على الصعيد الجيوسياسي سوف
اتحدث لك كانت هناك دول محايده مثل السويد
وفنلندا لم تنضم الى الناتو لانهم لم
يكونوا يودوا ان يكونوا جزءا من حلف
الناتو بعد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
تقدموا مباشره بعضويه الدخول الى الناتو
سويسرا الدوله المحايده على مر التاريخ
والتي لم تشارك في اي عقوبات على اي دوله
في العالم شاركت في حزمه العقوبات
الاوروبيه والغربيه على على روسيا اذا اين
هو تحقيق الاهداف الروسيه كما تدعي روسيا
الان بوتين وجيش الروسي وروسيا دخلت في
مازق وتورطت في حرب الاوكرانيه اذا
تراجعوا الى الخلف فسوف يخسرون امام شعبهم
الشعب الروسي تم بيعه الاوهام واذا ونحو
الامام لا يستطيعون التقدم لانهم في حاله
يرسى لها ليس شورتس هو الذي يرسى له وانما
بوتين الجالس في الكريميلين والذي تم
تزويده بمعلومات خاطئه من قبل مستش اري
بانه يمكن السيطره على اوكرانيا لذلك اذا
كانت لديك شفقه فقدمها لبوتين الذي اتيت
من هناك من موسكو في طريقك في العوده قدم
له هذه التعازي لبوتين وليس موقفه قوي هو
رئيس لدوله لها وزنها في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفي العالم والمانيا اليوم تقود المعسكر
الغربي ضد روسيا في اوكرانيا
طيب ابدا من الجمل الاخيره
اذا اليوم روسيا من تحارب هل تحارب
اوكرانيا ام تحارب كل دول حلف الناتو بما
فيها امريكا
والاف الجنود الاوكراني هاي بتصريح حضور
البرلمان الالماني الاف الجنود الاوكرانيا
يتدربون على الاراضي الاوكرانيه لاستخدام
الدبابات والمدافع التي سوف تقتل من الروس
ان كانوا على في اوكرانيا او ان كانوا
داخل روسيا
السويد وفنلندا السويد وفنلندا نعم تقدموا
بطلب هذا امر ليس يعني غريب علينا اذا كان
جورجيا تتقدم بطلب للدخول الى الناتو
بوتين اليوم طبعا ليس حسب الاحصاءات
الروسيه حسب الاحصاءات الاوروبيه
والامريكيه بانه هو الزعيم الوحيد الذي
يفرض كلمته على الساحه الدوليه قبل
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا في
امريكا كان بوتين يحصل على اصوات خلال
استفتاءات شعبيه اكثر من الرئيس الامريكي
المتواجد في حينها
نريد الان ان نتهم روسيا بانها هي وراء
زعزعه الامن في اوروبا وفي العالم كله
لروسيا طلب بسيط
حتى قبل 2014 نعود الى الموضوع الاوكراني
انا لا اتحدث عن التاريخ كان لروسيا طلب
صغير هو ان تدرج اوكرانيا في الدستور
بانها هي دوله محايده لن تنتسب لن تدخل في
اي كيانات عسكريه كانت غربيه او شرقيه هذا
الامر لم يحدث ولم يحدث الامر الثاني
بالنسبه
ذات سياده باي حق تطلب روسيا من اوكرانيا
هذا الطلب
اذا كوبا كوبا كدوله ذات سياده اليوم يحق
لها ان تطلب من روسيا احضار صواريخ
الشيطان اللي طبعا هي مسافتها 18 الف كيلو
متر ولكن بين كوبا وبين الولايات المتحده
الامريكي يمكن مئات كيلو المترات اذا كوبا
اليوم اريد ان اخذ هذا هذه النقطه ايضا
اذا كوبا كدوله مستقله يحق لها استضافه
الصواريخ ان كان النبويه او بعيده المدى
الى كوبا انت لم ترتقي الى ما احد وضع
الاسلحه
احكي احكي
اي استفزاز من قبل بس هاي الجمله لم يكن
هناك اي استفزاز لم يكن هناك اي استفزاز
من قبل الناتو لم يتم وضع صواريخ لمواجهه
روسيا في اوكرانيا الشعب الاوكراني
اختار الطريق الديمقراطيه والحريه وروسيا
لا تريد هذا الشيء لم يكن هناك اي مفاوضات
على دخول الناتو لم يكن هناك اي تثبيت
لاسلحه وصواريخ نوويه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه في مواجهه روسيا لذلك هذه
المقارنه بكوبا غير صحيحه اذا الشعب
الكوبي اختار الان طريق الحريه
والديمقراطيه وب علاقات مع دول اخرى فهذا
من حقه كما هو من حق الشعب الاوكراني يعني
لم يكن اصلا على الساحه يا سيد جاد انا
احترمك جدا احترمك تمثل شعب لانه ولكن انت
لم ترتقي الى مستوى السياسه تفكيرك الان
تفكير الحزب الاخضر
الايكولوجيا وحقوق النساء وحقوق الطفل
ارجو منك ان ترتقي الى مستوى السياسه
وتفكر بشيء استراتيجي
ما حصل حقوق النساء وحقوق الطفل مش سياسه
يعني انت ما بتحترم حقوق الطفل وحقوق
المراه انا خليني احط لك اياها
سابق خليني اعطينا بين قوسين معناته وخاصه
تعرف جماعه المثليين وحقوقهم نحن فيروسا
نرفضها نعم نحن علنا نرفض هذا الامر
نهائيا ونعتبره مخالف للطبيعه فلا لا يعني
لا تجبرني ادخل في حيثيات هذا الامر وجنس
الاطفال وهالامور واتركني خلينا نرجع
لموضوعنا الاساسي
ان شاء الله الموضوع الاوكراني ليس وليده
اليوم ولا الامس ولا ولا من ذوق اسابيع
الموضوع بدا من التسعينات عندما وافق
الاتحاد السوفيتي على دمج المانيا
الديمقراطيه والمانيا الغربيه في دوله
واحده على تفكير تفكيك حلف وارسو العسكري
الاشتراكي
عندما خرج الجيش الروسي من كل الدول في
اوروبا الشرقيه من بلغاريا ورومانيا دول
كلها معروفه
الغرب اعطى عهدا لروسيا الاتحاديه بانه لن
يكون هنالك تمددا لحلف الناتو في اتجاه
الشرق
تمدد يعني في العربي ولا يساعد على حدا
ولا حدا كويس روسيا في ذاك الوقت لم يكن
لديها القوه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والعسكريه لكي
تحامي عن نفسها او حتى نقول حتى ان تفرض
رايها اكثر من الف كيلو متر من عندكم من
برلين الى حدودنا قوات الناتو موجوده في
دولتك ام غير موجوده موجوده
المناورات العسكريه ناتو امريكا على مع
اوكرانيا موجوده نعم موجوده مع جورجيا
موجوده نعم موجوده روسيا تقول للغرب
لاوروبا
اتركوا روسيا في حاله امنه اعطونا فقط
ضمانين لا ثالثه لهما ان يتم توسيع الناتو
لا ترجع تقول لي هاي دوله مستقله لا يوجد
اليوم في العالم دوله مستقله لا يوجد لا
تجبرني احكي المخبه يعني لا في ما لا يوجد
ولا تقنعني بانه المانيا دوله مستقله لا
تقنعني ولا راح اقتنع واعتبرني جاي من
روسيا مع البوتين وما بفهم هالشي انا يعني
كيف
الالمانيه
على هاتفها الجوال ماذا فعلت
وتجسس معها قوات الامن الالمانيه بالاتفاق
مع الامريكيين بتحكي لي على
ما في انا كاخ اكبر منك مو اعرف منك
المستقله
في العالم خليني بس بس خليني على هاي
النقطه
هذا الموضوع
تلتقي في مصالحها تتعاون في بين فيما بين
فيما بينها لتحقيق اهدافها يعني اليوم
الصيني الروسي لا نقول بانه نحن معتمدين
على الصين او الصين معتمده على روسيا لا
ولكن هنالك تعاون وتفاهم
ومساعدات فيما بين البعض
تقول ال سيد جام انه والله الكل ضد روسيا
الهندود روسيا الصين ضد روسيا سمي لي دوله
عربيه واحده واحده لكي لا اذكر الاسماء ضد
روسيا افريقيا
روسيا الان عائده بقوه الى افريقيا والى
اسيا وعندها الامكانيات الماديه اكثر من
اوروبا
وانا الي رجاء عند السيد الدكتور فيصل يا
ريت نلتقي انا واياك بعد
سنه كامله كان لبعض الحوارات مع بعض
الاخوه في سوريا في موضوع السوريه وكل ما
تكلمنا به حصل بعد سنوات
ارجع اقول لك روسيا
لن تنهزمك خليني احكي انت حكيت الجملتين
انتهوا يعني
لم تضع هدفا اوكرانيا
انسحب المحيط
يا دكتور فيصل المباحثات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه في اسطنبول انسحبت انه هاي
خطوه
يعني كخطوه مستحبه جميل تفضل تفضل
يعني هو بيقول مين من الدول وقف مع مع
روسيا لم تقف مع روسيا حقيقه كان في ثلاث
قرارات دوليه ضد روسيا من الامم المتحده
في الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده اخرها
قبل عده ايام في الذكرى السنويه للحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
خليني اكمل ارجوك خليني اكمل الان
يا اخي خليني اكمل
هيك ما بيصير فيصل يا دكتور فيصل يعني
اكثر من 140 دوله صوتت لصالح قرار تجريم
روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا كم دوله وقفت
مع روسيا خمس او سته دول هي من اشباه
الدول وانصاف الدول منهم نيكاراغوا كوريا
الشماليه نصف دوله
بيلاروسيا اريتريا التي يهمني
وليس من صور هذه الدول التي وقفت مع روسيا
خليني اكمل
اذا مش ضعيف ما راح تقاطع خليني اكمل هذه
الدول حتى التي انت تتباهى بدعمها لروسيا
اللي هم الهند والصين ايضا امتنعوا عن
التصويت يعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفرض عقوبات
على ايران وعلى الصين ومع ذلك هذه الدول
لم تتجرا على التصويت مع روسيا جاوب على
هذا السؤال ما الذي يمنع ايران من التصويت
لصالح روسيا لماذا لم تصوت لماذا امتنعت
ايران التي
تترنح تحت العقوبات الامريكيه يعني دوله
عظمى تعتبر نفسها روسيا اذا كانت بين
قوسين دوله عظمى دوله اخرى تفرض عليها
عقوبات ودول اخرى لا تستطيع التضامن معها
هذه الدول التي تكلمت عنها تحاول
الاستفاده من الترنح الروسي روسيا اليوم
في ورطه الجميع يحاول الاستفاد من الغاز
الروسي الرخيص الذي اصبح غير مقبول في
العالم اصبح يباع
بابخاس الاسنان روسيا تدفع الضرائب باهظه
لهذه الحرب على اوكرانيا يعني انا لا افهم
ما هي الانتصارات التي انت تريد ان تبيعها
للعالم لا تستطيع ان تقدم الارقام اي
انتصار على ارض الواقع يعني يا رجل
ماريوبول مدينه صغيره جيش دوله تعتبر
نفسها دوله عظمى احتاجت الى اشهر من اجل
دخولها بعد انتكبت مجازر ودمرت البنيه
التحتيه والشعب هناك امتنع من العوده الى
ماريوف واليوم مدينه مهجوره نفس الحرب
تجري الان في باه موت وجميع المدن
الاوكرانيه التي تقاوم تدخلها روسيا بعد
ان تدمرها عن بكره ابيها ولا يبقى فيها اي
شخص حتى مناطق الشرقيه في اوكرانيا الروس
الموجودون هناك لا يودون ان بقاء في هذه
المشكله
عليها
الوقت مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا اشكر
ضيفينا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور زياد
سبسبي وعبر الاقمار الصناعيه جان عمر
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين وفيصل القاسم يحييكم من الدوله
[موسيقى]